l'ouverture au public se fera demain
l'enseigne culturel le furet du nord
débarqua skywest après plusieurs mois de
travaux c'est au coeur du projet de
revitalisation du centre commercial de
30 mille mètres carrés bonsoir michael
denny draw vous êtes en direct depuis le
centre commercial
une arrivée qui témoigne de la stratégie
de skywest tourner désormais vers les
loisirs et la culture
grégory vous le disiez le centre
commercial sqy ouest qui est basé ici à
montigny le bretonneux est en train de
trouver une nouvelle impulsion pour nous
expliquer cette nouvelle dynamique je
suis avec le directeur du centre
mohammed mazzolari l'arrivée des furet
du nord
ici à mon type hôtelier skywest martèle
le début d'une nouvelle ère pour le
centre commercial
oui bonjour michael alors effectivement
nous avons plaisir de relancer le centre
commercial sqy ouest et ce renouveau est
lancée avec cette première pierre à
l'édifice l'ouverture de furet du nord
qui arrivera qui demandent donc du coup
demain matin à 10 heures donc donc
forcément c'est une nouvelle ère qui
s'annonce pour mon team retenue et pour
ce test
alors c'est l'aboutissement d'un travail
de plusieurs années d'un projet qu'on a
voulu tourner sur la culture le sport et
le loisir
un projet qui est venu compléter une
offre déjà existante sur espace 50 ans
qui d'ailleurs petite parenthèse fêtera
ses 30 ans et les festivités
commenceront demain et qui viendra
compléter l'offre déjà présente sur
espace saint quentin en répondant à une
cible de clientèle en recherche
justement de loisirs l'arrivée des furet
du nord va-t-elle être suivie d'autres
annonces dans les prochaines semaines ou
dans les prochains mois bien évidemment
on va pas s'arrêter là vient le
contraire donc dans le sens je peux vous
annoncer sur courant 2010 8 courant
deuxième semestre 2018 par exemple sur
le thème du loisir l'arrivée d'ayem qui
est une enseigne de loisirs créée par
deux lyonnais avec un seul
une seule enseigne sur lyon est donc le
second arrivera en région parisienne et
plus précisément sur skywest donc on
aura le plaisir de les accueillir et qui
proposera de la simulation de voitures
de formule 1 sur vérins par exemple donc
l'arrivée des forêts du nord marque un
tournant vraiment dans le centre
commercial sqy ouest
on se recentre plutôt sur la culture et
les loisirs c'est une vraie volonté de
la part des clients
alors c'est une vraie demande on a la
chance de pouvoir établir régulièrement
des études clientèle qui nous ont permis
effectivement devenir affiner notre
notre projet et il y avait une vraie
attente sur ce domaine justement sur le
sur le loisir
alors l'arrivée d'alou et courant 2010
il sera complété par d'autres
d'autres enseignes dans la restauration
par exemple nous accueillerons hobby
chef qui est une enseigne de beagle
fraîche burritos une enseigne mexicaine
vraiment des enseignes qui apporte
quelque chose de nouveau et comme je
disais tout à l'heure qui vient
compléter une offre plus standards qu'on
retrouve sur le centre commercial espace
saint quentin
vous avez fait des études pour recentrer
skywest vers le loisir
nous réalisons déjà des études tous les
deux ans où nous questionnons nos nos
clients sur leurs points de satisfaction
leurs attentes de ces de ces études nous
en ressortons des conclusions et ses
conclusions nous permettre justement de
construire des projets donc alors c'est
pour ça que ça prend plus beaucoup de
temps plus de plusieurs mois peut voir
plusieurs années parce qu'en plus des
négociations effectivement maintenant
cette proximité avec nos clients de
manière à répondre à leurs attentes
merci beaucoup mohamed est bon démarrage
de main pour les férus du nord je le
rappelle c'est demain mercredi à skywest
que les furet du nord ouvrent leurs
portes
merci à vous michael est aussi à patrick
jacques de dixmude au cadrage vous le
rappeler l'enseigne culturelle des furet
du nord qui ouvrira donc demain à
skywest après plusieurs mois de travaux